so here i'm going to talk about the
gradient and in this video i'm only
going to describe how you compute the
gradient and in the next couple ones i'm
going to give the geometric
interpretation and i hate doing this i
hate showing the computation before the
geometric intuition since usually it
should go the other way around but the
gradient is one of those weird things
where the way that you compute it
actually seems kind of unrelated to the
intuition and you'll see that we'll
connect them in the next few videos but
to do that we need to know what both of
them actually are so on the computation
side of things let's say you have some
sort of function and i'm just going to
make it a two variable function and
let's say it's f of x y
equals x squared sine of y
the gradient is a way of packing
together all the partial derivative
information of a function so let's just
start by computing the partial
derivatives of this guy so
partial of f with respect to x
is equal to so we look at this and we
consider x the variable and y the
constant well in that case sine of y is
also a constant you know as far as x is
concerned the derivative of x is 2x so
we see that this will be 2 x times that
constant sine of y
sine of y
whereas the partial derivative
with respect to y
now we look up here and we say x is
considered a constant so x squared is
also considered a constant so this is
just a constant times sine of y
so that's going to equal
that same constant times the cosine of y
which is the derivative of sine
so now what the gradient does is it just
puts both of these together in a vector
and specifically let me all
change colors here
you denote it with a little upside down
triangle
the name of that symbol is nabla but you
often just pronounce it del you'd say
del f or gradient of f
and what this equals
is a vector
that has those two partial derivatives
in it so the first one is the partial
derivative with respect to x to x times
sine of y
the bottom one partial derivative with
respect to y
x squared
cosine of y
and notice maybe i should emphasize this
is actually a vector-valued function
right
so
maybe i'll give it a little bit more
room here and emphasize
that it's got an x and a y
this is a function that takes in
a point in two-dimensional space and
outputs a two-dimensional vector
so you could also imagine doing this
with three different variables then you
would have three partial derivatives and
a three-dimensional output
and the way you might write this more
generally as we could go down here and
say the gradient
of any function
is equal to a vector
with its partial derivatives
partial of f with respect to x
and partial of f with respect to y
and in some sense you know we call these
partial derivatives i like to think of
the gradient as the full derivative
because it kind of captures all of the
information that you need
so a very helpful mnemonic device with
the gradient is to think about this
triangle this nabla symbol
as being a vector
full of partial derivative operators and
by operator i just mean you know here
let's like partial with respect to x
something where you could give it a
function and it gives you another
function so you give this guy you know
the function f and it gives you this
expression this multivariable function
as a result so the nabla symbol is this
vector full of different partial
derivative operators
and in this case it might just be two of
them
and this is kind of a weird thing right
because it's like what this is a vector
it's got like operators in it that's not
what i thought vectors do um but you can
kind of see where it's going it's really
just a
you could think of it as a memory trick
but it's in some sense a little bit
deeper than that
and really when you take this triangle
and you say okay let's take this
triangle and you can kind of imagine
multiplying it by f really it's like an
operator taking in this function and
it's going to give you another function
it's like you take this triangle and you
put an f in front of it
and you can imagine like this part gets
multiplied quote unquote multiplied with
f this part gets quote-unquote
multiplied with f but really you're just
saying you you take the partial
derivative with respect to x and then
with y and on and on and the reason for
doing this this symbol comes up a lot in
other contexts there are two other
operators that you're going to learn
about called the divergence and the curl
i'll get to those later all in due time
but it's useful to think about this
vector-ish thing of partial derivatives
and i mean one one weird thing about it
you could say okay so this this nabla
symbol is a vector of partial derivative
operators what's its dimension
and it's you know it's like how many
dimensions you got because if you had a
three-dimensional function that would
mean that you should treat this like
it's got three different operators as
part of it
and you know i'd kind of
finish this off down here
and if you had something that was 100
dimensional it would have 100 dimension
100 different operators in it and that's
fine it's really just again kind of a
memory trick so with that that's how you
compute the gradient not too much to it
it's pretty much just partial
derivatives but you smack them into a
vector where it gets fun and where it
gets interesting is with the geometric
interpretation i'll get to that in the
next couple videos it's also a super
important tool for something called the
directional derivative
so you've got a lot of fun stuff ahead